. This is very, very interesting.
Many Republicans have been demanding smaller
packages from Democrats, as we talked about
yesterday.
Jen Psaki, regularly.
Minded of the fact that all these different
Republicans say Biden's package is too big,
they need a smaller package, Mitt Romney is
doing something very interesting.
Mitt Romney is a Republican senator.
He has a proposal to provide three thousand
dollars per child to millions of American
families.
And this would be a form of bipartisan support
for Joe Biden's covid relief plan, which includes
expanding child benefits.
Now it's a slightly different framework.
Romney would give forty two hundred dollars
per year per child up to age six.
That goes down to three thousand dollars per
year per child for age six to 17.
And how that would interact with some of these
other elements is in the details that that
we are still learning about.
But what is very interesting about this is
that one of the reasons that Mitt Romney and
maybe some other Republicans are interested
in this is that they think if you give these
bigger payments to people, they will be less
likely to file the return.
I'm sorry.
Let me go backwards.
Republicans believe that giving payments would
discourage parents from finding jobs.
And this is their concern with what Mitt Romney
and also with what Joe Biden are proposing.
This is this very old trope that we hear from
the right, which is predicated on the idea
that everybody's lazy and nobody has any drive
or motivation.
And people just want to figure out how to
not work at all.
Most people, you know, there's an evolutionary
thing to this.
And when we read some very interesting articles
about, you know, people who feel unfulfilled
and all these different things, there are
practical reasons for that, people seeking
meaning and fulfillment.
But there may also be an evolutionary reason,
which is when you were fulfilled, human advancement
potentially stopped.
When you were satisfied, you stopped trying
to improve your circumstances and those of
your children and their children and so on.
So there may even be an evolutionary basis
for this.
But most people want to do something most
people want, meaning?
Yes, there are some people who, for a variety
of different reasons, want the easiest path
out.
If I can just sit at home and not work and
collect money, that's fine.
Most people don't want that.
Most people want one job that pays well so
that they can have some meaning coming from
employment and also have the financial wherewithal
to be able to raise kids, put food on the
table for family, participate in life in other
ways.
And this Republican idea that if you do this,
it always assumes the worst about people's
intentions and the worst about humanity.
And that's really how these Republicans see
people.
But I'm glad to see Mitt Romney proposing
proposing an alternative to this.
Now, this is going to be the way that Romney's
idea would be integrated, is that Mitt Romney
wants it to be an amendment to the Democratic
budget resolution.
And it looks as though a budget resolution,
budget reconciliation is increasingly likely
to be the way that this covid relief bill
is going to be passed.
And as I've said before, the fact that Democrats
can pass this without any Republican involvement
to me signals the time for so-called negotiation
with Republicans is over.
But I don't believe every Republican will
vote against it.
I believe that there are Republicans that
either for personal political convictions
or because of their realization that covid
relief is popular with their constituents.
Some Republicans are going to vote for this
and put up call them on their bluff.
Right.
See if they actually are all going to vote
against the one point nine dollars billion
package.
If that's what Democrat Democrats go forward
with, I don't believe that they will.
And in particular now with Mitt Romney jumping
in, which makes this listen, I always thought
it was naive to think you're going to get
this big bipartisan covid relief bill when
the party of Republicans is the party of obstruction,
but merely Mitt Romney saying, here's an idea
and then I'm in favor of it.
It makes it technically bipartisan, even if
nobody else comes on board.
So I think these are very, very interesting
developments.
And to be very clear, I know there are people
who keep writing to me saying, Davey boy,
why aren't you calling out Biden for the fact
that he said 2000 and now it's fourteen hundred?
And why aren't you calling out Biden for the
fact that he said the checks would go out
right away and they haven't?
I have called him out.
I called him out in just about every segment
I've done, including on yesterday's show.
Joe Biden has already not done what he promised,
which is he said it would be two thousand
dollars not to not 14 to get to a total of
two thousand with the last stimulus, Joe Biden
said.
Two thousand dollar checks, now they're talking
about 4500, that's already a problem.
Joe Biden also said if Democrats win the two
seats in Georgia, checks go out right away.
Well, it's already February.
I understand this takes a little bit of time,
but it's time to move forward.
It's time to do it with budget reconciliation,
whether or not Republicans want to be involved.
And I hope I mean, listen, if Mitt Romney
proposing even more money for children is
the way to make it bipartisan and get more
Republicans to support it, great.
If not, it's time for Democrats to get it
done by themselves.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.